hi my name is ty Gailey I work in kernel
development at Wolfram research the
title of my talk is introducing the
Wolfram client library for Java this is
a new Java library designed to make it
very easy to call the Wolfram engine
whether the engine is running locally in
the cloud and particularly with cloud
deployed api's
hello everyone my name is ty Gailey i'll
be talking to you today about a new
project I'm working on called the wolf
and client library for Java so what is
this library and why do we need it well
in the old days there was Mathematica
then it was good being a user of Wolfram
technology meant sitting in front of the
Mathematica notebook fine and typing
into it nowadays though we have Wolfram
engine deployed in all sorts of
different ways and all sort of different
places in addition to desktop products
like Mathematica and wool from desktop
we have the Wolfram cloud available from
enterprise private clouds we
particularly have these cloud deployed
api's we've got web Mathematica
we've got kernels running in mobile
devices we've got even more exotic
things like kernels running behind a
link server and we've got other things
coming down the pike so what we really
need what users really need is a simple
and unified way to access this Wolfram
language technology no matter where it's
deployed
hence the Wolfram client library for
Java in particular having Wolfram
language technology available in the
Wolfram cloud means that you can write
programs for yourself and for your
colleagues for your customers that you
as Wolfram language functionality
without requiring them to have
Mathematica or any other Wolfram engine
product installed locally so we have all
this great technology in the Wolfram
language we've got all these easy ways
to deploy it and expose it to users or
really need is libraries for a bunch of
different program programming languages
like developers call this from you know
their favorite development environment
alright so here's a curveball probably
weren't expecting a slide about Wolfram
script in this talk but I do want to
take a little aside to talk about the
relationship of this library to Wolfram
script people maybe don't even know what
wolf script is it's it's a command-line
tool it's like a launcher for the
Wolfram kernel but Wolfram script
has some very interesting functionality
that maybe people don't know about these
are just screenshots directly from the
documentation I move from script and you
can see if you say - code - plus 2 then
obviously it computes 2 plus 2 this
launches of local copy of the welcome
colonel and executes the code there but
in this in the next line this is where
the magic happens if you just say -
cloud that runs that talks to a cloud
kernel and executes that same code in
the cloud so here with absolutely no
effort and no change to anything other
than putting - cloud in front of it
you've doing this magic thing of
computing something in a cloud kernel
and you could also run cloud api's in
this third example is very simply you
saved actually API you give the URL
which has been shortened here and then
the arguments and suddenly you you've
called the Wolfram cloud API now maybe
people aren't all that interested in
this it's a command-line tool maybe you
don't care about command-line tools and
obviously it's limited in the sense that
sort of textual input and output only
it's not really much for software
development but Wolfram script is a
unified interface to call in Wolfram
technology --ml way so Wolfram client
line for Java in other client libraries
I mean it's telling them short to say
that they were just Wolfram script for
that other language but in some sense
fundamentally this is a little bit of
the model for the wulfing client layer
for Java wanted to be able to write a
Java lie yeah I want to give people the
Java library that lets people call
Wolfram languages in different
environments with essentially no
modification of their code alright so
this is a slide you might have expected
to see in this talk
what's the relations are the Vistage a
link we have this Java library for many
years called j-link that is used to call
Mathematica we call the Wolfram language
so the Wolfram client library is in no
way a replacement for J link instead it
sits on top of J link if you are using
the Wolfram client library to talk to a
local
welcome colonel or any other colonel
that you have attached to the a J link
Colonel link you know that is math link
or W STP then you're gonna be using
jailing under the hood it uses jailing
for all that functionality it integrates
fully with jailing cadet if like I was
saying if you if you use J link if you
write some jailing code that requires a
link to a colonel which is what you do
when you're writing J link programs in
Java then you can simply use that link
as the target for your calls using the
wulfing client library for Java you can
go back and forth between writings with
manual J then code to talk on the link
or using the wulfing client library api
to communicating certainly I think for
users who don't need the slightly more
advanced features of J link the Wolfen
client leverage for java is going to be
a little easier to use but really most
important it provides many features that
are not in jail e like : kernels in the
cloud either for api's or direct
computations for criminals so really
it's it's the cloud stuff it is really
the thing that J link doesn't have okay
so in a slightly new direction for
Wolfram this is going to be an open
source project it will be a bit made
available on github it's not available
I'm giving off yet people maybe saw that
well from client library for Python
talked earlier today I guess they
managed to get out of get up before the
talk so good for them but the G good for
them I see the wolf in client library is
not quite ready for github its github
debut yet but before long and we
certainly hope that others will
contribute to the library is this large
enough for people to read in the back
because this is at 150% I don't want to
have to zoom it alright
so we planted client ladders from
multiple languages we're talking at this
conference about the Java that I'm
developing and the Python one that was
talked about earlier ah but we were we
will write others in the future we're
certainly hoping that other developers
will contribute libraries for other
languages people maybe perhaps people
will be writing in Java like languages
will use the Java version that's a bit
of a model for theirs or if you're
writing and maybe in a more Python like
language you might use the our Python
one as a model alright so here's some of
the general design principles when I was
writing this library one its targeting
dependents know the target is the term I
use in the library for the the wolfram
engine that you're pointing so it's this
is really the fundamental feature I want
to be able to write code that talks to a
local woman kernel and you can change it
to talk to a cloud kernel change it to
talk to a different target without
changing essentially anything about your
code you just pointed at a different
place and the code runs unmodified in
fact my test file for this you know
hundreds of test cases I just change one
line to point it at a different target
cloud local kernel in it and it runs
unmodified you want to make it easy to
send and receive native Java types I
don't want you to have to stringify
arguments or something to a self or
compose specialized things like JSON
objects or something unless you know
that's what you've got I'm gonna be able
to send and receive integer arrays just
native Java things job images things
like that we will see this in the code
later but encapsulate the result any
errors and metadata in a result object
very convenient that way to have it all
in a single object and I don't throw
most of the methods don't throw checked
exceptions and this goes along with the
previous thing instead of throwing an
exception and having you deal with the
exception I return an object from every
call if there was an error then the
object is marked as not success and you
can interrogate the exception that was
thrown by looking at the object
it also supports trivial change to
between asynchronous and synchronous
evaluations so if you want to start a
call and have it have your habit
returned immediately and then later on
interrogate what other thing was
finished you can do that very simply you
don't have to worry about creating
threads and managing that sort of thing
yourself and finally I want a small and
simple API alright so there's three main
classes one is Wolfram call which is
used to evaluate arbitrary code
expressions this is this is your
evaluation function
there's Wolfram API call which is used
to evaluate api's it's a little
different you have named arguments and
things like that in an API call and you
know the API is of wolfen call more from
API call are almost identical they're
very very similar it's easy to go back
and forth from one to the other if you
know one and finally there's a class
called Wolfram session which represents
a persistent kernel session I don't
think I'll talk about this in the talk
cause it's a lot of people will use this
class but it's just a way Wolfram
session is essentially a factory for
creating these call objects so you can
read it about in the documentation and
won't really talk about it alright so
here we go some actual code can you see
these colors this is supposed to be sort
of yellow and this is this is yellow
this is green I can see the blue but I
don't know if I see this it's all washed
out oh well alright fine anyway so here
is a complete program is the only
complete program I will show in this
talk because no one cares about all this
junk at the beginning and at the end but
this is an actual complete program that
launches a local kernel and evaluates
this trivial so I'm actually using
colors to delineate three different
sections this is in the section where we
sort of create the call and configure it
here we call we perform it using the
perform method and then here in this
final block we sort of interrogate the
thing and see what we got back people
might be confused about this notation
here it's really just one line new
wolfram called dot set input 15
factorial the methods in the wulfing
call class they all return the welcome
call objects so you can chain them
together you know Wolfen called dot set
this tide set that that surf this dot
perform and I'd like that style of
program it's very concise but I often
break a line like this and you'll see
that these lines will stack up in later
sections where we're doing more things
to the call it's very convenient I think
very readable notation so we just played
a Wolfram call object we set the input
to be 15 factorial supplied as a string
in this case then perform is the method
that does the work and you know we asked
whether it was successful and if so we
do we get this Wolfram call result
object is the thing that encapsulates
the result in exceptions and metadata
and then we can interrogate it and get
the result back you notice it's a string
in this case the default result type is
a string now I do want to point out that
there's no there's no J linking here
right there's no import jaylene classes
or anything that we are using J link
under the hood but you don't you know
you don't have to import any J of the
classes yes right so the question is
what is the target of this wolfram call
and the default target is a local kernel
with the sort of guest
default path which is
I'm cheating a little bit because I I
got the right path in my computer but
lots of people would have to you know
use a path in this in the wolf and call
constructor to point at the correct
colonel alright so there we have it very
similar program in a complete program
right so so that was the evaluate this
thing in a local kernel so what if I
want to point at a cloud I want to ask
the cloud to evaluate this and just see
I got I got all this pink it's supposed
to delineate the changed bits can you
see that this chunk is a different color
okay that's it's probably too bright or
something anyway oh well all I have to
do is I call set target and pointing at
the the cloud based URL of the wulfing
cloud now there is a there is a constant
in the library that is this URL but I
put it in the code here just so you can
see more clearly so I simply add set
target cloud and then everything else
about the the program runs exactly the
same so this is like the - cloud in in
the Wolfram script example right so
that's simple I just call set target and
I pointed a different execution engine
so the possible targets for this well a
path to a local kernel one is a JD
kernel link object so if you use J link
to you know mathlete factory dot create
kernel link all that you used to having
to acquire a kernel link then you can
simply use that as the target for one of
these woman calls or you know I just
showed the cloud the base URL to the
Wolfram cloud or you know your own
private cloud alright so now I'm going
to shift gears because there's lots of
features of this library but I'm going
to show them really in the context of an
API call it it's probably a little more
interesting so we're gonna jump now to
using Wolfram API call which is the
class yep are you giving me the
right so calling cloudy API is that's
what Wolfe maybe I calls about so
targets there's a public cloud that's
the default target but you could also
point at a Wolfram Enterprise private
cloud and you know other things that we
have coming alright so here we go so we
in these slides usually at the top
there's a cloud deploy command which
deploys some simple API and then I'll
show the program that calls it from Java
so here's a trivial cloud deploy it
takes one argument called exit just
squares it and you notice I say
permissions goes to public just because
they don't want have to deal with
authentication and permissions in this
code at the moment so one way to specify
that the endpoint for this call is to
set you your ID function see lots of
people they don't realize that you can
name your api's so they get these
horrific you ought you you IDs in the
api beam but if you do that then you can
just set you you ID and put that ugly
string in there so we just create the
call we set the endpoint for the call
and then we add an argument called X put
the value for t to perform and it's
exact same the rest of the code is
exactly it's just like a Wolfram call
so let's look at some argument type
flexibility so here in this case we have
a cloud deploy it's just picks for
arguments W X Y Z they're all integers
it just multiplies them together
here I give it a sensible name so here's
how I prepare the call I call set end
point I give the you know the end point
minus the prefix which I can leave out
so here you notice I can give it integer
I can give a string that will you know
turn into an integer I can give it a
Java integer object and I can give it an
expert that represents integer exper is
a jail in class that represents
arbitrary Wolfram language expressions
in Java so I flex 2 billion how I
specify it and I slipped another feature
in this thing this set result type in
the past me Royce getting results back
as strings that's the default result
play but if I want an integer if I
expect this API call to return integer I
can say set was a fault type there's all
type time integer and then you notice
here when I get the result I cast it to
an integer it will be an integer and I
know this cast will work because if this
thing can't
if imager couldn't have been created by
this call then an exception an error
would have been thrown this not success
you know the success thing would not be
true so we have flexibility in how we
supply joggers now this is a simple
example but if you had an API that took
a raise or something like that you know
you could pass the same sorts of
arguments of experts that represented
arrays or you know native Java arrays so
this is just a the enum class in the
library that shows all the different
result types you can specify exper which
is very convenient to represent anything
expert class is very good if you get
something and you want to send it back
you don't really care what it was but
you want to send it back as an argument
to the next call you just get something
as an expert and pump it in as argument
to a future call then you know you could
say string binary which is a array of
bytes an image you can delecti say image
and get a job image back various things
so here's an example of using the result
type image so here in this API you
notice that
it's a plot command the US this third
argument JPEG this is the export form
argument for API function so this API is
written to return a picture so when I'm
calling an API like that I just say set
result type image and then you notice in
the get result thing will be a Java
image object and then whatever I do
whatever I want with this display it or
something like that so it trivially
simple to get back an image all right so
the slide has to be open because I have
to give a little preamble to this those
result type specifications result type
integer is a
they don't coerce the result into
something of that type
they say I'm expecting to get something
like this back and when I call get
result I want it to be cast of that type
that previous API they return an image
was written to return an image but what
if you have an API that does not written
to return image but I've decided that
instead I wanted back as an image right
there is a way in the in the you know
cloud deploy API to specify to allow
users to specify alternate you know
export forms for their things and it's a
little tricky you have to know about
this allowed cloud extra parameters so
you you see this allowed cloud extra
parameters those to underscore export
for them so you have to tell your API I
will allow people to specify alternate
export forms it's kind of obscure in
fact I'm writing specific one but it's
really easier just to say allowed cloud
extra parameters goes to all I mean we
don't it's not the default cuz we might
be considered security risk that other
people call your API is which are
running on your dime and export it to
something else maybe you don't want
people using up cloud credits to convert
something to some other format but if
you specify this when you deploy and you
specifically allowing
export form changes then you could you
put this into things so anyway here I
it's the same thing but here I say set
export form JPEG and then a result type
image and I'm getting the thing to note
here is that the the author of this API
did not write it to return an image okay
I mean yes it's a plot command but if
you did this without setting the export
form you just get a graphics expression
back right this could be two plus two
and if you did it you get a picture of
the number four instead of the number
four back so you have the ability to
specify your alternate result form then
the author of the API put in there
originally if they deploy in such a way
that you know gives you call this
permission to do that okay we also do
asynchronous execution there's some API
that takes a long time there's a limit
on how long cloudy ApS could run but
your listeners say it's at least a few
seconds so the only thing I do
differently is I call perform async and
instead of getting back a wolfram call
result I get back a future a little
phone call result future is just a
standard class in the java language it
represents the future result and you
know what future interface has that is
like is done so later on i can
interrogate whether it's done it has a
method called get which returns the
result if i call yet on a future it will
block until the thing returns so I might
you know periodically interrogate
whether it's done and called yet if I
don't want to wait or I can just call
get right away and wait for it to return
but the point here is that I don't have
to mess with threats right of course a
thread spun off in the background to
perform this call I don't have to do
thing of that I just say perform async I
get a future back and I can you know
interrogate this future use it how I
want in in the rest of my code
just some quick examples for
authentication permissions here's an API
that was without there was no
permissions goes to public here so this
is a private API so one way I want to
call my own private API is one way to do
it is I can call generate security
authentication key and they get
something back a security authentication
key that has fields for key and secret
and so I would look at this object and I
would you know I just do this once in
Mathematica
well logged in I get a security
medication key that represents me and I
take the strings from this key and I can
put them into my Java program and with
the set off credentials and call these
private EP is another way to control who
can call you API is is to use this
permissions permissions goal is to
permissions key some key goes to execute
so what I'm saying here is that anyone
can call this API as long as they
provide this permissions key known as
some key and so if I have it I can call
set permissions key some key and then
I'll be able to call that API from from
Java you could also receive evaluation
metadata and that includes extra things
like the timing information you can get
any print or messages that were
generated during API does extremely
useful because a lots of times something
doesn't go right you know you have no
idea to figure out you get so get
something unexpected back if there were
a message is the issue you can you can
determine what they are now you again
for this you have to speak this is also
one of those allowed product or
parameters the deploy the API has to
allow you to change the response form so
this doesn't work for any old API but if
I had said you know if you just say all
here it's it's a little bit easier but
just just say allowed politics to
private goes to all when you deploy your
api's and save yourself a lot of hassle
so again we just say select evaluation
data true and if we do that then the
Wolfen call result object comes back has
get metadata people have metadata in it
you can get the metadata out and you can
get its
is actually incorrect string it is an
array of strings and princes an array of
strings so you can get any messages and
any print output generated you can also
get the timing of the thing don't really
have time for my demo but maybe I'll but
it anyways because I don't have any
after this so that's just just trivial
example of a interesting cloud API that
maybe you want exposed to users I've got
maybe you've seen that Wolfram language
has this ability to take images and and
modify them in all sorts interesting way
so it automatically so I'm calling this
van Gogh ization right so this this
neural network can take a picture and
kind of make it look like a van Gogh
painting so all I have to do to create
to expose this incredibly cool piece of
ultimate language functionality to the
world is say cloud deploy API function I
say that it takes one argument called M
which will be understood as it's an
image expression or a you know image
data coming in and that's the that is
the code for the API just called net
model applied it to the image and and I
say I'm returning it I want to return a
picture and that's it so if I've
deployed this now how do I call it from
will compliant library well anyway
here's a example picture lovely picture
of and here's what the code looks like
in Java so this is the only thing that
you would need to write to call that API
I also want to point out that all this
Co here the bottom is just sort of
boilerplate Java for displaying the
image right and this is just boilerplate
Java for reading it in off the disk so
this just reads this image file off my
disk set in point out arguments that
result that image perform the call get
the result it comes right back in as a
native java image and then i just used
some standard java code to display it
i'm not going to run this as a java
program because I don't want to write
java programs instead i
I'm gonna write a jailing program I'm
gonna run this while I'm talking it
takes a few seconds here okay launch and
set up but there we go so that's what
that thing looks like so maybe I mean
this is a pretty useful thing you maybe
want to relive an Android app that lets
people take pictures and press a button
and they did a little van Gogh ization
of the picture it's that simple it's
just a handful of lines of Java code
this magic here this is just instead of
fed of writing the Java program and
compiling it I'm writing some code in
the Wolfram language it uses a link to
call my java library right this is not
the local mathematic evaluating this I'm
literally using the Wolfram client
library for Java I'm just calling it
from mathematic using tailing because I
don't want to leave the Mathematica
environment for my demo though anyway
it's literally just a handful of lines
of code to produce this program
conclusion look for it on github
before long thank you very much
[Applause]